bonjour et merci d'être sur arte France
une première réaction général ni
confinement ni couvre-feu en France face
à la 5e vague le gouvernement a-t-il
raison de ne pas aller si loin selon
vous
Bonjour tout à fait d'accord le
confinement je passe à pas du tout lieu
d'être on voit qu'à décale mais beaucoup
de gens sont vaccinés ça freine quand
même la surcharge les hôpitaux je trouve
pas le peuple le confinement ça sera
important
le rappel vaccinal par contre alors tu
me rappelles me gêne un petit peu moi je
préfère employer le terme anglo-saxon
c'est vraiment une histoire de booster
booster l'immunité on sait qu'on est au
bout de 5 mois solution pas attraper la
maladie covid
juste été vacciné protection anti
corbess et de refaire une injection d'un
mètre de booster l'immunité durablement
donc c'est vraiment booster ses booster
l'immunité pour que les gens ne sois pas
malade et surtout sur le récupère le
plus rapidement possible
la vaccination pour les 5 ans 11 ans la
France et réfléchis mais ce ne serait
pas avant 2011 et qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
c'est vrai que les enfants ne font peu
de forme grave ils font des forme plutôt
bénigne comme une grippe
donc pour ses enfants je pense pas que
c'est une bonne idée par contre laisser
la possibilité des parents qui le
souhaitent de signer leurs enfants ça
par contre ça serait bien sur la base du
volontariat
les enfants il n'y aura plus de
fermeture de classe en primaire c'est à
vous en mettre une bonne solution
pratique en tout cas pour les parents
visiblement
je n'ai pas les éléments pour répondre à
votre question
[Musique]
je te déteste pour le sanitaire va être
amené à 24 heures contre 72 heures
jusque-là là aussi c'est un moyen
densité à la vaccination
alors c'est c'est un moyen concrètement
né le 25 novembre ceux qui sont pas avec
si le 25 novembre c'est qui le veulent
pas
[Musique]
se battre moi de mon côté
personnellement dans mon cabinet je suis
déjà avec les malades hivernale qu'on
démarrer je suis déjà plus de 100 %
l'activité là j'ai regardé mes messages
je suis à 126 % de remplissage de mes
plage de consultation je vais pas me
battre pour faire vacciner une personne
qui veut pas donc après c'est une
décision de réduire la valise et tu
passes à 24 heures c'est un choix
je sais pas si ça a changé beaucoup de
gens
va être de nouveau obligatoire partout
en intérieur est-ce que l'une des
priorités pour faire une vague mais pas
surtout de renforcer de penser à nouveau
aux barrières
je suis absolument d'accord à 300 % on
l'a vu l'année dernière l'hiver dernier
les gens faisait attention les gens
porter le masque Eugène hydro-alcoolique
se réunissaient pas on n'a pas eu le
temps la gastro cette année on a les
premières commencer dans 7 ans on a de
la gastro on a des branchies
l'hôpital les urgences pédiatriques
pour conclure votre intervention parce
qu'elle pourrait vous donner que vous
pouvez me ment est sur la bonne voie
est-ce qu'il est encore temps avec ses
mesures qui viennent d'être annoncé donc
5e vague en France
la 5e vague landing et peut-être mais il
faut pas oublier que si c'est aussi
difficile aussi aussi compliqué c'est
parce que notre système de santé est
foutu faut pas oublier que l'hôpital est
surchargé faut pas oublier que les
médecins libéraux sont surchargés et
s'il y avait un peu plus de facilité de
la marge de manœuvre on n'en serait pas
là en catastrophe ouvrir des unités la
forcer les gens ce
qu'ils pouvaient assumer la chute de
malade mais beaucoup moins de problème
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à Pascal
généraliste